new yorker lieblingsinsel der deutschen
nur ein winziger teil davon ist der
ballermann ist die hölle hölle hölle der
st auf tourismus es gibt auch ein luxus
mallorca was natürlich auch noch keine
garantie für guten geschmack ist
mallorca ganz oben es gibt aber auch ein
mallorca ganz unten und zwar im
doppelten wortsinn
eine höhle 20 quadratmeter groß egal
herd eine rostige gasflasche und ein
bett das ist das heim von lota etwa zwei
kilometer entfernt von ballermann party
und feierwütigen lebt der 61 jährige ich
muss jeder kennt aber jeden tag es gibt
nicht was mir geschenkt wird und dann
sittlich manchmal hier
wie viel muss ich noch nicht
wir treffen lothar an einem supermarkt
hier sitzt der vormittags um wie er es
nennt geschäfte zu machen er hofft auf
geld und lebensmittel dir zum überleben
in seiner höhle braucht jeden tag sitzt
der dort zwischen 9 und 11 uhr dann
würde es ihm zu heiß und er kehrt in
sein steiniges heim zurück wir dürfen
ihn begleiten
wird eine höhle ist ganz schön versteckt
seit knapp 20 jahren lebt lothar in der
wildnis drei gar zu weihnachten über 30
grad im sommer die leute kennen und
schätzen den ehemaligen kaufmann wir
können ihn alle her das ist klar und er
hat einen guten ruf ständig hier und was
vorher war will ja keiner wissen
ich habe in meinem leben so viel
durchgemacht
ich bin das zeige ich euch gerne
mehrmals abgestorbenen angeschossen
worden
ursprünglich kommt lothar aus kleve dort
geht es ihm lange zeit gut bis er auf
die schiefe bahn gerät erzählt von raub
kokainhandel rotlicht und banküberfällen
2004 kam ich an
ich kam aus dem knast ich hab den ersten
flieger genommen der gekommen das war
mir vollkommen egal
bin ich hier gelandet
lothar ist gern für sich allein er
schätzt das leben was er jetzt führt
auch wenn es manchmal nicht leicht ist
[Musik]
das hat doch alles keinen sinn mehr
verstehst du an dich selbst
fühle mich haben will dann soll er mich
holen aber mutig noch mehr erleiden
luther schwelgt oft in erinnerungen vor
allem denkt er an seine kinder hier
zurückgelassen hat und an seine
verstorbene mutter
[Musik]
von richtigen heimweh trotzdem keine
spur
kommt wieder mein ego dass ich hab einen
auf der rechten in ofterdingen schulung
der linke schulter sagte zu mir komm du
arsch asche
lag es doch ist man muss aufgehen musik
bewegen man muss gucken man muss suchen
empfindet immer ehren etwas luthers
höhle sie macht ihn nicht überglücklich
trotzdem ist er zufrieden mit seinem
leben lothar der höhlenmensch von
mallorca ich habe es mir selber
ausgesucht weil wenn ich jetzt auch
finanziell die möglichkeit hätte würde
ich mir natürlich in der kleinen wohnung
mieten oder so aber ich hab gesagt hier
bist du selbst
[Musik]